[Music]
hello there
welcome to a mindful moment with
stillwater
we are so glad you can join us
did you know looking and listening to
our surroundings can help relax and calm
the mind
you might even discover something new
so today we're going to use our ears to
be mindful
and listen to the world around us
[Music]
ah
do you hear that
the wind rustles the trees
a single leaf
falls to the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
listen to stillwater playing his zhao
[Music]
sitting next to his peaceful pond
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
do you know that sound
rainfall
is perfect for listening
[Applause]
[Music]
i think the birds have had enough rain
for the day
[Music]
do you hear the cat's purr
he loves to help stillwater rake the
crunchy leaves
[Music]
and the crickets chirp
as the day winds down
great job listening today
so how do you feel now actually a lot
better i think it's wonderful you've
come out here to be so present in the
world around you very good work
thank you stillwater i'm proud of you
for trying i'm proud of me too
[Music]
you